lanar keys.com I'm currently sitting in
a 2021 Jeep Cheroke key
latitude um this is the AL fobic remote
key customer had one key there they had
us make a second one and as we know
uh Daimler Chrysler Dodge Jeep Fiat um
most models 2018 and up are going to
require the uh Gateway cable which one
of the Jeeps is under the dash it's it's
back under there good but you'll see the
green connector you pull that one little
cover down and look up there you see the
green connector and you can just clip
right in and
then I have my auto km 100 Bluetooth
Dongo and then a short uh USB extension
unplugged into the OBD2 port and it was
uh pretty straightforward programming
pulled the pin number uh if you do a
mobilizer status scan and uh guide it it
will also pull the pin number and it
keep programming took all of
maybe 25
seconds um so yeah it's kind of hard to
see what the screen glare but see in
step two they originally had two keys
and then program was succeeded and now
this three keys in the system the keys
themselves when I looked them up um on
my suppliers website they did not have
uh 2021 listed in the
aftermarket which I had um but the O was
listed as 2014 to
2021 so the aftermarket keys I had were
listed 2014 to
2019 um it's still the same key
obviously if the OEM one's still the
same key so this one did work um I had
an extra button here that they just had
the regular three button case these fbcs
when you open them up they're actually
the same uh the border is all populated
so I'm just going to put this in a three
button case um it's already programmed
programming was
successful um you
know
[Music]
all right so I'll put a new Durell
battery in it and uh cuz I'm not sure
how long this one's been in my van and
just put it in uh that three button
configuration and they would be good to
go so I just want to make a real quick
video so if anybody's running into you
know 2021 and doesn't know where the
Gateway connector is I just wanted to
show them that and then just to let them
know that from 20 uh 14 to 2021 it's the
same key even though you know major
supplies might listed up to
2019 all right lanar keys.com